Yes.
Hey,
you already dealt with court order.
When we considered the syntax of romance,
Noun phrases like Isla may have been a day and verb phrases like doomy Ludy
case.
One easy way to build longer phrases is to use particles,
specifically conjunctions like and or or mice.
But do wait,
they go,
Uni gone through it.
Scribble.
I sing and I write,
but there's more to full romance sentences than this.
Okay?
Basic sentences have a subject followed by a verb followed by the verbs.
Object.
You wanted to get the love every tattoo.
Illumio.
Amika.
[inaudible].
Okay.
That order remains.
Even if we substitute a pronoun for the subject [inaudible] of course,
we've seen how these subjects can and do just drop out sentences like
[inaudible] current,
vulgar,
Latin,
and nearly all the romance languages besides French match and their closest
relatives.
The basic word order changes when we substitute in object pronouns,
he laid [inaudible],
but la La [inaudible] kit or simply Isla de kid.
The order here is subject than object Pronoun.
Then the verb,
this also applies to indirect objects and other small unstressed clinic Pronoun
set cozy up to the verb.
Me.
Laddie Kate.
Okay.
Negative statements work like affirmative ones and typically add a negative
particle known for not before the verb.
Noun d Kit Nandi Katie
lovery Tata
that no one also comes before any of the object pronouns.
Elaine leaned [inaudible] get
okay
in French and Romance,
the Latin negative particle has become weaker and speakers added a new negative
reinforcer after the verb to Yona.
Say,
bitch,
you shouldn't sit uh,
these languages along with Occitan can actually delete the original particle
before the verb and keep their innovated negative after the verb.
Schipol Sabine Pass for,
I don't know,
other negative words like never and nothing may follow the verb.
This makes double negatives or even triple negation.
A regular feature of romance,
AGM or the thin,
either Eleanor,
Ds,
Nada,
yen,
each anemic.
Literally,
she doesn't say nothing or she doesn't say anything.
Questions can keep the structure of affirmative sentences.
He laid the get the levity.
Tata elite dictate the levity.
Tata Ilima Laddie Kit.
The subject may move after the verb to signal that a question's being asked to
Dq salivary tattoo,
because to elaborate data,
he led the kids too.
Some languages keep the basic word order,
but may prompt the question with [inaudible] literally,
is it that
blow acid to fee
tuna fish?
Sardinian has a question marking particle and move subjects after verbs and who
fucking store
question words like the Pronoun Quid and the adverb Quandl start with a quote in
Latin.
They're moved to the front of the sentence in romance
with dks.
Give views.
Give each,
she says each,
oh meaning,
what
do you say?
Sometimes the subject is the one being asked about.
We did get the library today.
If it's not,
the subject may still move to the right of the verb.
Do Decay Salivary Tata,
we'd Dk is to
hear you are the subject and what is the object.
This short introduction to basic romance sentences gives us some momentum as we
push into more complicated statements.
That's the topic for next time.
Until then,
keep your Latin Volker.